you're a guy  where  what you know on below the belt i always  break down the cards and and star  certain fights and whenever you're on  the card i'm like oh [ __ ] vicente is on  the guard because we know you're gonna  bring it man i've been doing and i've  done enough to get that title shot i  believe especially the way i win the the  fights i put on you know they're really  exciting that's that's my trademark  let's say like i'm not a trash talker  you know i'm not gonna sell my fights by  talking trash about my opponent but i  sell my fights with my style everybody  wants to watch whenever whenever like  they announce my fights i get a lot of  support from the fans they are i know  that they're gonna you know put it on  their agenda they're gonna make sure  they watch that fight because we know  you're gonna bring it  haters will say haters will say haters  will say anything every day every day  just to make sure you don't chase a  dream they gonna go i'm gonna step